well the pandemic changed a lot of
things for a lot of people including
moms to be with concerns spiked a new
trend for expectant mothers home births
heather mills explains the concern among
some medical experts
the number of home births increased 22
percent during the height of the
pandemic the highest level since 1990
according to the cdc
she's the best thing that came out of
the pandemic yeah it was great but two
years ago when athena was about to come
into the world it was the peak of the
pandemic an uncertain and scary time
especially for moms about to give birth
and like april may they were like not
allowing anybody in the hospital i was
just terrified to go into the hospital
alone so after doing her homework on
home births camilla decided not to go to
the hospital it was beautiful it was
really beautiful it was of course like
there was
we were nervous it was a full house her
husband and toddler by her side along
with two midwives a doula and her
pediatrician remember i was laying down
in my bed
and like they saw the head
and i started pushing and then she was
born and she was not breathing so that
was i think the most
stressful part after like a minute she
like started doing these like really
cute noises and moving and took her
first breath but she never really cried
but not every woman is a candidate for
home birth ultimately one of the major
obstetrical risks is the baby's
shoulders being stuck and you may only
have seconds to few minutes to deliver
that baby and
may be difficult to transport mom and
baby in in that kind of emergency
setting
panise haideri has had to have important
and serious conversations with many of
her patients considering home births she
says there's one statistic that for many
isn't worth the risk there is a two to
three fold
of
perinatal loss death associated with
home birth for camilla she's glad she
had the option that many women don't i
felt like really empowered to
have her at home
and of course i was afraid
as the day came closer you know
but it ended up being great dr haideri
says as women are giving birth at an
older age they may have more complex
medical issues so she says the best
conversation to have is with your
physician heather mills live local now